- We've got five suggestions,
but we'll do a rap.
It will be delightful.
People in this section here,
what would you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member] Pyramids.
- Pyramids?
- [Audience Member 2] Why?
- Someone just said why.
Let me ask you this,
why pyramids?
- [Audience Member] It's a great shape.
- It's a great shape.
(audience laughs)
- That's pretty good. Okay.
So the suggestion isn't pyramids,
the suggestion is pyramids
are a great shape.
I like that.
Thank you.
Let's come to this kind
of trapezoidal wedge
over and around here.
What would you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member 3] Destiny's Child.
- Destiny's child? Yeaaaah.
No one's debating that.
Pyramids are a great
shape, Destiny's child.
If you are in this area here,
what would you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member 4] Dick!
Dick, dick.
- So maybe not plentiful.
Wait what did you say?
(crowd laughs)
- [Audience Member 4] Dick.
- Dick?
(crowd guffaws)
Would you please describe this dick?
And don't be too obvious.
- [Audience Member 4] Big dick.
Humongous!
- You said big dick, humongous.
But then down here,
(audience laughs)
- Would you,
would you repeat what you said?
It was really good.
I was about to say it came into my head
which it didn't.
(audience laughs)
(clapping)
It entered me airily.
Would you mind repeating it?
- [Audience Member 5] I
don't know what I said.
- You, we know what you said.
No no,
because there was there was,
it was,
there was a specific,
it was real descriptive there.
- [Audience Member 6] Say it. Say it!
- [Audience Member 5] He
said he wanted girthy.
(laughter)
- It was prefaced by the words,
nine inches long and girthy.
(crowd laughs)
I don't know why you're hiding that
and like suddenly you were like
kind of
"oh I feel weird that I
didn't shoot for the moon
with a twelve".
No one wants a twelve.
It was random? No it was very specific.
It was, I need to describe it with a
"nine inches long and girthy".
(audience laughs)
And there's nothing wrong
with knowing what you like.
That's fine.
- [Audience Member] Big dick!
- So, a dick,
which is nine inches long and girthy.
Pyramids are a great shape.
Destiny's child.
I would like two more suggestions,
knowing full well
that neither of them aren't going to be
as delightful as that one.
But, I haven't asked this area.
What would you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member 7] Anxious dentist.
- An anxious dentist,
was that... yeah?
Lovely.
There's a lovely, um,
internal running for that.
I was trying to think of
the correct linguistic term
but I cannot for the life of
me because it's quite late.
One final suggestion,
this could come from anywhere.
What would you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member 8] Tinder dates!
- Tinder dates,
are you on one?
(crowd laughs)
There's nothing shameful about that.
Okay. Tinder dates.
Let's... this is a terrible sound.
Okay, cool.
Well, this is going to be a rap.
That's a freestyle made up on the spot.
Oh my God.
I, I pick a newbie every show.
This one's really fast
and it might be too late,
but let's, let's try it.
So this is a rap based
on those suggestions.
Pyramids are a great shape,
and nine inches long and girthy,
dick,
Destiny's child,
tinder dates,
and an anxious dentist,
and then it's going to be really fun.
(beat starts playing)
- Let's enjoy this.
Oh my gosh this is too quick.
(crowd cheers)
Too quick like we're flipping a lid,
let me take those lines
let me draw pyramids.
I be out in Egypt
like all these ages
lookin' out at them,
I fly out,
I don't need it.
I read ya.
Walk there across the sun
Feelin all the ends of seas with my hand.
If you don't get that word in your head
Then the end to see is
comin' to a shape at the edge
Lookin' at the cube,
boy, lookin' at the sphere,
I'm like, na, shit get outta here.
I only gon' do more polyganormal
pyramids,
it's like they got four walls
they're gonna meet at the center,
the point on the top,
lookin like another vein
just that they popped.
They shoot in the light from the luxe orb,
Pyramids,
That's a great shape and
he said it in his forum.
Three points and the crowd goes wild
Three ladies in Destiny's Child
(crowd cheers)
- We've got Michelle,
Kelley,
Beyonce,
(crowd cheers)
She's the green on the scene,
Rule #1's and they ever heard of Beam
But, Destiny,
They were so delicious,
Lookin' at those backsides
Bootylicious
Gettin' down on the floor
Down on the stage,
I was like twelve years old
Felt bein
On my area
I'm aware of ya
I'm encouraged by all this
Not scared of ya.
Any word in the universe
Look, you could pick
You would write at the back
with the core as a dick
Like D-I-C-K
Should we choose
Trying to get some word from you
You were like
Humongous,
but right among us,
someone was like
I got that hunger
for the perfect words.
I deserve these.
You want to get the nice nice
Want to get the girthy
Girthy is basically the way around
What's the diameter?
What have you found?
3 times 3, that's 9
Always got the size of ya dick online
(audience cheering)
- When you got a girl
and a human inside
When you wanna talk with
the girl from the ride
Now, maybe,
We can talk that later
When I want to wear the debt
As I say it I hate ya
Why
Why do you feel anxious
Your hands are shakin'
He was thinkin'' of the
dick last night he was bakin
(audience cheers)
- He was giving oral
on my dong in the gums
All the while hangin'
other dick in his bum
I can see it, bro
But I don't mean to gloat
You got the nice dentist,
You got the white coat
And I'm sittin'
I just feel a little type of tingle
I was like that's fine
If you want to mingle
Bumble and Tinder
It can go awry
If you go on a date when
you swipe left or right
When I'm over there
I can see the smile on the back
You be like, "whoa!"
With the raps
you don't slack
I be out on the date
with a guy and he lies
Turnin' up
He was like
Stuck up two size
No he was not he was 5 foot 10
And I learned he was an Ire
Not born dead
On his little bio
He was like
Nine low.
And I was like,
Na, like 5 for the strong
5 plus 1
Why you even lyin'?
When I get down there
See ya,
I'm sighin'
Like, shit.
Doesn't even matter
I won't go there.
Beggers can't be choosers so I move lower
Still.
Ya have to take things
Serve me
More power
kind of (inaudible).
(audience cheers)
(beat continues)